I have family who are born and raised in  Britain and they don't use swear words  but I got a text from my aunt who said  WTF astana  no I mean seriously WTF about the ending  you know the only burn we knew is God  it's tragic but whatever happened to her  during those years you changed her Emily  in season 2 is dealing with the fallout  of what she realized at the very end of  season 1 and again I've watched season 1  I'm gonna get to it  [Music]  I think I'm game paranoid  [Music]  there's an element of this character  whose sense of self whose identity is  completely fractured so she's now  working on putting the pieces together  trying to figure out the empty spaces  which are a very kind of remote and  foggy memory that is going to come back  and going to come into play the second  season  are you okay  nothing is as it seems nobody is who  they seem to be and just when you think  you know who a person is or what's going  to happen you're wrong